it's kind of a sore subject but um biden
as mentioned did have his press
conference
yesterday timing it exactly is that is
it is it a coincidence
that the one president only the second
press conference he gives in a year
happens to air at the same time as my dr
phil appearance coincidence
probably but
maybe not
um
he uh so we'll go through a couple of
his answers here
he's asked about why he um
called most of the country jim crow
racist and um
you know is he is he a very angry man
who hates
most of the citizens of this country is
that why
his answer doesn't do much to allay
those that suspicion let's listen
you campaigned and you ran on a return
to civility and i know that you dispute
the characterization that you called
folks who would oppose those voting
bills um as being bull connor or george
wallace but you said that they would be
sort of in the same camp no i didn't say
that look what i said go back and read
what i said
and tell me
if you think i called
anyone who voted on the side of the
position taken by bull connor that they
were bull connor
and that is an interesting reading of
english you you i assume you got into in
the journals because you like to write
so did you expect that that would work
with senators mansion or or cinema
um
there's certain things that are so
consequential you have to speak from
your heart as well as your head
i was speaking out
forcefully on what i think to be at
stake
that's what it is and by the way
no one
no one forgets who was on the side of
king or verse on or bull connor
no one not done that the history books
will noted when i was making the case
don't think this is a freebie
you don't get to vote this way and then
somehow it goes away this will be stick
with you the rest of your career and
long after you're gone
what a disaster um
you know our our
enemies
watch
this
and they are they're licking their chops
you see this man who has clearly lost
his mind he's a dementia patient
you know there's the people on the right
that complain that we don't get more
press conferences
i i i hope we don't have another one for
the rest of his presidency
i hope this is the last i i wish that he
would never address the public ever
again
address us with uh in written word you
know send it send a memo send an email
that we'll all get
because having him up i don't see how it
does anybody any good to have him losing
his mind visibly on camera
um doesn't do us any good
unless the people who are
in a position to do it will actually
take steps
to get rid of this guy
because he's not mentally competent but
that's that's not gonna happen
so i hope there's not another press
conference
two years too much if you feel like you
are getting the respect you deserve in
life well i've got a solution for you
established titles is your opportunity
to earn the title of lord or lady and
gain the respect you deserve all you
need is a one square foot plot of land
in scotland in your title pack you'll
receive at least one square foot of
dedicated land on a private estate and
an official certificate with a crest
your certificate will include a unique
plot number with which you can see the
exact location of your land these title
packs are a fantastic gift and the best
way to surprise your loved ones from
girlfriends of boyfriends or even family
you could even get a couple pack for you
and your partner where you can get
adjoining plots of land
well with this certificate you could
officially change your name to lord or
lady and get it on your credit card your
plane ticket etc
establish titles is having a great
extended new year's sale so go to
establishtitles.com matt walsh to save
10 off today and remember to use the
discount code matt walsh or just click
the link below that's established titles
dot com matt walsh or just click the
link below what even is his
justification he says i guess it's just
his rationale here is that
no no i said that you were on the side
of bull connor
and uh and george wallace
i didn't say that you were those people
that actually is a rationale come on i
didn't i didn't accuse everyone of being
bull connor i just said they were well
we know that
we know you didn't you weren't saying
they literally are that person
but you were equating them with that
person
if they won't uh support a voting rights
bill to protect the rights that
everybody already has
and speaking of voting he was also asked
about well if we don't get this voting
rights bill in place
and then we get to the midterm elections
you know okay are you willing can you
sit here and just assure everybody
assure the american people that the
elections are still legitimate
especially because we've been told
repeatedly over the last year year and a
half
that the worst thing you could ever do
is question the legitimacy of our
elections that is an attack on our very
democracy our system of government
it's an attack on our society
let's see how uh joe biden fields that
question
speaking of voting rights legislation if
this isn't passed do you still believe
the upcoming election will be fairly
conducted and its results will be
legitimate
well it all depends on
whether or not
we're able to
make
the case to the american people that
some of this is being set up to try to
alter the outcome of the election
okay so in other words if i don't get my
way then yes the elections are
illegitimate
and it's just uh it's just a coincidence
but so you understand all this is a
coincidence the fact that they are
almost certainly going to going to be
annihilated in the midterms the
democrats are walking into a bloodbath
and there's no escaping it now and they
know it
and the fact that that's about to happen
and now is when they're launching
this full-on campaign
screaming about an attack on voting
rights and people are being prevented
from voting
all the coincidence right
no this is well i'll tell you what it's
not this is not as i've explained many
times this is not a double standard it
sounds like a double standard
when you hear him the president united
states standing in front of the american
people and openly
um and in advance questioning the
legitimacy and therefore the results of
an upcoming election
when you hear him doing that
after he and the rest of democrats spent
the last year condemning trump for doing
something similar
you might say that's a double standard
it's not a double standard
there is one standard here
and the one standard again is
it's okay when they do it
whatever maybe we'll put it this way
whatever they are doing is okay
because it's them
and whatever their opponents are doing
is bad
because they're the opponents that's the
standard
there's a certain um
coherence to it not really there's no
moral coherence but it's at least
understandable
and that's that's all it is one standard
they can do it but not you
that's the case when it comes to
questioning elections that's the case
when it comes to
uh attending a masculist
party
they can do it but not you hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated